states that legalized recreational
marijuana are confused by a move by
Attorney General Jeff Sessions he
reversed the Obama administration's
hands-off federal policy toward pot
yesterday a memo from sessions calls
marijuana use quote a serious crime that
could be prosecuted under federal laws
Mireya Villarreal is in a shop in West
Hollywood California that started
selling recreational pot this week Maria
good morning
well good morning this store and many
others like it across the state have
spent the last few - Guinea ready
complying with new state regulation so
that they can actually sell recreational
marijuana now the owners here and others
across the country are worried that one
single memo coming out of Washington DC
could turn them all into criminals the
xen Healey marijuana dispensary in West
Hollywood California has had a steady
stream of customers since legal
recreational sales started here on
Monday but now the next people through
the door could be federal authorities
coming to shut them down it's always
possibility in your mind that they'll go
after the most successful one first to
make an example California is one of six
states along with the District of
Columbia where recreational pot sales
have been legalized but under federal
law it's still illegal to grow buy or
use marijuana under the Obama
administration it was federal policy to
respect state marijuana laws by
reversing that policy the US attorney
general's office is now giving
permission for states to prosecute
marijuana cases but without a clear
directive to do so the move drew strong
objections from many in states that have
legalized recreational pot including
Colorado's Republican senator Cory
Gardner in 2016 President Trump came to
Colorado and said he believed in states
rights that he wouldn't use legal powers
to reverse a Colorado's decision
why does Jeff Sessions think that
President Trump was wrong the senator
tweeted that he would take all steps
necessary to fight the policy change
including possibly holding up the Senate
from voting on pending Justice
Department nominees Colorado Oregon and
California all say they have no plans to
change their prosecution strategies
they have the public support a recent
poll says acceptance of legal marijuana
is at an all-time high
64 percent legal experts say that level
of acceptance could make federal
prosecutions difficult when they
actually have to try this case and they
end up in front of a jury that has voted
for the legalization of marijuana you
could see something like jury
nullification and no convictions some
cannabis farmers are already
reconsidering their applications for
licenses because it would put them on a
public list available to investigators
and prosecutors this store AWS WeHo in
West Hollywood was raided three times
before 2013 all of their merchandise was
either confiscated or destroyed so that
fear is absolutely real that's a good
point Mariah thank you